2020 has been a year of incredible loss
in january the world stood still when
news broke that basketball legend kobe
bryant and his daughter gianna had been
killed along with seven other people in
a helicopter crash
then in august the tragic news of the
unexpected death of black panther actor
chadwick boseman broke
while bozeman and bryant weren't known
as collaborators in life
a story that bozeman shared after
brian's death has shined a light on what
could have been a game-changing
partnership between the two men
the recollection came during an episode
of hbo's round table discussion show the
shop
uninterrupted during a wide-ranging
conversation with fellow icons such as
tiffany haddish and nfl quarterback
patrick mahomes bozeman touched on his
relationship with the late basketball
star
saying i had like four conversations
with him he's not somebody that i was
best friends with
but the crazy thing is in those four
conversations
when he passed it felt like somebody
that i knew
bozeman also shared some details about
one of those conversations he had with
bryant in the years before his death
in the wake of bozeman's own untimely
passing that particular conversation now
has a deeper and more haunting
significance
bozeman closed out the show with a story
about his powerful first encounter with
the legendary basketball player which
appears to have occurred during
the 2018 awards season referring to
bryant's oscar win for best animated
short film for dear basketball bozeman
said
first time i saw him was before he won
the oscar it was crazy because we were
sitting at a party talking about
philosophers and poetry and like that's
who he was
he was like you know this is what i'm
into right now as a as a
as an artist not not as a basketball
player
that was when bozeman proposed that they
work on a project together
what bryant said in response now has an
eerie context
according to bozeman bryant was
interested in the idea of a
collaboration but then grew
introspective
as bozeman put it it was quote like he
was meditating like he was seeing it
and he looked up at me he said two years
he it's like he saw the whole thing
unfold
sadly that collaboration never came to
be both bryant and bozeman passed away
in 2020 which would have been about two
years after their initial conversation
although bryant is primarily remembered
for his basketball career his oscar win
was the beginning of a new phase for the
black mamba as a powerhouse in the world
of business and entertainment
but i've always throughout my career
i've always just wanted to
do the best that i could in 2014 he
started his own company which among
other projects co-produced dear
basketball
in a statement to espn at the time the
company launched he said
i have always had ideas and always had a
vision of where i wanted to go
going back to 2000. now once the
achilles injury took place i'm sitting
at home for months not moving a couple
things set in
one is that there are only so many
modern family episodes a person can
watch
and then two what do i do now the
company's first big project was an
investment in the sports drink body
armor but his creativity wasn't simply
relegated to his business dealings
in that same espn interview bryant
revealed that he was working on a few
other creative projects
including a series of novels he said i
wake up in the morning i can't wait to
write
i can't wait to get to the studio i love
telling stories i love
you know inspiring kids or providing
them with tools that are going to help
them
this side of bryant was clearly not lost
in bozeman after bryant's death bozeman
tweeted a touching photo
tribute with a caption that described
him as husband
father strategist philosopher poet
warrior athlete
filmmaker your focus is magnetic kobe at
the end of his story about his possible
collaboration with bryant on the shop
chadwick hinted that the conversation
strengthened his admiration for the
basketball legend
and i said to my fiance i said yo he is
who they say he is